past so olivia when you're ready when
you're sitting live please
live now chad um
thank you well welcome to this meeting
of
on the 9th of november without further
ado
apologies for absence and
non-received chairman thank you
thank you disclosures of interest
any disclosures of interest
i'll take well i've got one that may
apply
and that is for
the paper agenda item 12
uh we're at one stage and i'm not sure
whether i still am or not i was a member
of the center for public scrutiny
advisory board
and that might come up in relation to uh
item 12 on the agenda
so um and no
more disclosures of interest minutes
uh are people happy with the minutes of
the meeting held on the 5th of october
yes i was in attendance at the meeting
i'm not recording as big now fine
and uh thank you for reminding me
counselor kettle it's very remiss of you
but i should welcome you to the
your first formal cabinet meeting so
welcome counselor kettle and we look
forward to your contributions
may they be short and to the point
i don't know why mr parkland is laughing
i always try to do my best to play
as brief as possible thank you
councillor kettle
right um so
no more comments on the meeting so
subject to
uh councillor kettles uh point
then the minutes of the meeting on the
5th of october are accepted
so moving on matters to be referred to
the council
uh item 4 uh adoption of the
infrastructure funding statement uh
council of pemberton thank you very much
chairman um members of cabinet the
report before you
uh is relation to the infrastructure
funding statement for the year
1920 and it is
the recommendation that's being sought
is that
the infrastructure funding statement be
adopted um
the background to this is that the
government's reforms that gave
life to the uh community infrastructure
levy
uh required that all local authorities
uh put together
an annual infrastructure statement uh to
include as a minimum
a list of infrastructure projects a
report setting out
standard information on financial and
non-financial income and spend details
for the previous
year related to section 106 agreements
uh a community infrastructure levy
report standard setting
out information in the standardized form
on income and spend
relating to sill and remit and outlining
the minimum requirements
that the infrastructure statement
meets the council's community
infrastructure levy spending protocol
so the report that is before you um is
the statement for the year 1920
um and really probably that there will
be the point to
to to stop and to take any observations
questions
from members um before
moving to the recommendations which are
to adopt the statements
that the allocation of receipts for 1920
and 21 are based on receipts received
and also allowing for the planning
policy manager
in conjunction with the deputy leader to
make um
to publish and to make uh minor uh
grammatical changes to
uh the annual statements setting out um
the approach so i'll stop there and take
some ques any questions or
observations
uh joel you have a question
yeah it's taken me a while to unmute
because i appreciate you
yeah this isn't as facetious as it's
going to come out
i am always worried about something like
project 16
the nhs transforming lives by
transforming i.t oh dear
um what degree
of control or uh
understanding do we have of that once
it's rolled out or
do we hand over the money and we just
watch them um
spend it that's the nhsit project
so the uh the infrastructure list
is in essence the long list of projects
that we we have
and when we get to considering the
detail then
um there's a detailed uh spec brought
forward
by whoever's bringing the project
forward um
we would anticipate there being
um some reporting back about the
delivery of
the relevant piece of investment
and i just want to um endorse project 20
and 21 both of which are absolutely
vital and personally i think should be
number one and number two on the list
but you'll see that they're both in my
portfolio so you'll understand why
thank you no surprise there against
barca
councillor cargill
you muted counselor cargill
okay still mute okay i'm sorry okay i
couldn't see where to raise the hand
function is it seems to have disappeared
off mine
anyway i'll come to you that's not
deliberate honestly
okay first i i do uh on 3.2.5
uh refurbishment of the greg hall yes
thank you very much indeed that's a
really
worthwhile project as you know for
ulster and if i can just turn to 37
though
i noticed that there seems to be a
disconnect between
when the money is spent and um
the district what the districts have
actually allocated
is there any way that's right the parish
is being allocated
is there any way we can sort of pull all
those together into more of a sequence i
don't know if it's
it's just the timing of this thing so
that we can get a a firmer picture
of how much has been spent by the
parishes out of the potty within the
time period
a year so there is a mismatch between
the reporting timelines
for sil for us as an authority
and the reporting timelines for tan and
parish councils about their sill spend
it is just the way the government have
set this up so
i think we will be able to bring forward
an information sheet
further down the track and then do that
on an annual basis
but it will be out of sync with this i'm
afraid to say okay
just a thought thank you no it it it's
there and you will get an information
sheet about tan and paris spending it's
something that officers
are alive too uh
ann councillor parry
sorry uh sorry leader i'm having
problems with my mute
mute on and off button i just wanted to
make a comment really
um in that are welcome that there seems
to be a good
spread of projects right across the
district
which i do hope will certainly please
our
councillors in the southam um area in
in particular and i think you know it's
it's
it's pleasing to see that we have got
you know
a fairly fairly good spread of different
things going on across the district
um and it's good to see it's not just
stratfor centric
or you know a point well made councillor
parry uh
councillor barker another question
followed by councillor junard
and councillor o'donnell
councillor barker
mute my mute override for councillor
barker is working well i see today
shut up i'm on look at me
i mean honestly someone needs to sort
this out here
um no i wanted to say exactly the same
as ann said actually
which i is i'm quite pleased at the
spread the only point
i wanted to make is that there are a few
things on here
um so for instance a few couple of
things in the canal quarter that
potentially could be things that would
be projects that all
to be slung in together or done at the
same time just to make sense of
a particular bit of infrastructure and i
hope that this won't be
parked on the shelf
but will be a live document that informs
every project
and other development that might be
coming along related to it
so for instance on the uh where is it
this
the seven medal meadows cycle route
there just
might have to be a way through put in
that depending on other things we might
be doing
so just just to make it useful rather
than
yeah councillor barker and
you know i would say that generally
speaking every report
that is produced should be a living
document should be something we're
referring to
if we're producing statements policies
and they're just sat on shelves
then why are we wasting our time doing
them so you're absolutely right it is
uh absolutely right and proper that we
uh we refer to the statement and
we are uh smart about how we
pull projects together how we leverage
other opportunities to deliver on these
projects
uh so your point is well made and i
would also make the point that um
just for clarity that um um it is
projects that are brought to us
uh and it is you know we we are
encouraging projects to come forward
from across the district so it is
heartening to see that that these
projects have been brought to us and
bids made
from all across the district and that
that's a really good thing
okay uh councillor junaid
uh right uh if i could raise a couple of
questions that were raised at the
overview and scrutiny
uh first and then a couple of questions
from myself
from the ovary and scrutiny the question
that was raised one was
um that should there be consultation at
a later stage
uh now that this shortlist has is going
forward
um just to make sure that people are
happy with
the projects and the other question that
was raised
was uh the eminence of climate change
making sure that that
did have uh not just moderate moderately
positive but
significantly uh positive uh was a
question that was raised
okay shall i address those two first
because i can only i can only hold two
questions in my head at any one time
come back on my own absolutely but to
just to repeat the answers that i gave
at overview
overview and scrutiny yes when you get
to the business end of any of these
projects coming
there is an expectation well not just an
expectation a requirement
that the project sponsors undergo a
a public consultation to ensure that
there is uh a rigorous test of
uh the the desire and the need for the
project and
full engagement across the piece um as
far as
climate change is concerned i think i
made the the comment to overview and
scrutiny
that um you can take it as read that in
everything that we do
we have declared a climate change
emergency and climate change
and our response to it around
adaptations
and mitigation uh is writ large in
everything that this organization will
be doing so
i think i just made the observation that
um
we don't need to have it every time we
know it's in there so for the avoidance
of doubt we absolutely
are committed to uh the uh
the the objective that we have set uh
and everything that we do from here on
in
drives towards that end i think you've
got two more questions as well so
i could do two at a time well just just
very briefly
uh because um two of the uh at least two
of the projects
uh are within the ulster one has been
mentioned the ulster greg hall
uh but the other one is flood risk
massive management and there's also
another flood risk management
coming up and as another project and
given that um the leader has said that
um
adaptation really has to be central to
what the council's doing i do hope
uh that they get um that you do um
you um you know okay
wait but the other finally uh given the
point that somebody said about
um the diversity of uh questions of
projects
how do other people how other groups
input
um to uh future ifs
uh shortlists is that evidence is that
um known amongst widely enough so that
people can put forward projects
okay so we did an exercise but what i
think i'll do is if i can bring john
carefoot in to bring
uh to give you some detail on on how we
get the message out about uh projects in
the future
john would you like to help there please
uh thank you deputy leader uh afternoon
members
um yes we we've certainly broadened
the um uh the range of stakeholders will
be invited
to uh seek uh submissions from
uh this time round um i think it's about
getting the right
right balance um
members can you hear me yes yes
okay um it's yeah so we've broadened the
uh amounts of um the breadth of
stakeholders uh we've we've consulted on
this time round and engaged and that
reflects i think the um the breadth of
uh projects that have come
forward um i think to some extent we are
um i don't say hampered but we we're so
restricted by the fact we
the definition of infrastructure and
thinking of a district-wide
um perspective and so i
i suppose i would be slightly cautious
about wanting to
consult every local group
across the district that's not to say
they haven't
valid um projects but i think they
those particular local projects are more
suited
to the seal monies that the town and
parish councils
are able to spend so it's about getting
the right balance
uh getting that broad range of
stakeholders who i think we've
perhaps got about right now but it is
really a focus on if you're not the
wider more strategic infrastructure
which tends to be
mostly the the larger organizations but
if members um
think there's someone we haven't
consulted then we've certainly
endeavoured to do that
next time around thank you
council o'donnell thank you leader
um so just going back first of all
um council pemberton to the the very
wise point that councillor barca raised
about
the nhs it project now we all know the
huge amounts of money that can be lost
in nhs and it and i speak as someone
who's worked many years in the nhs
you said you anticipate some reporting
back on this i would hope for some
for a slightly more specific reporting
back and a timeline
on that because money just gets followed
up into these projects and i think what
councilor bark was driving out and i
know that something was drawn up
as a concern to me was how specific are
we in the outcomes for these projects
how detailed is our management of these
projects to check that the money's gone
where they said it was going to go and
we've achieved the goal that was
anticipated that was the first point and
then the second one
is with and this goes back slightly to
john carefort's points about
the stakeholders that have been engaged
in applying for these various projects
what happens to the ones who weren't
successful how do we feed back to them
about
applying next time the money gates are
open as it were and they can put in for
their projects what guidance do we give
to show we've been fully transparent
with the pro former etcetera
to make sure that there's equal
consideration given to all projects
i know there's a good spread this time
but to make sure the ones who haven't
been successful
may seek to reapply and have some
guidance on how to do that more
successfully next time if it's
appropriate
so i'll pick the first point up uh i
think just to
to refine the answer um when we get to
the point where
um we're actually signing off on these
projects that's the point at which we
would
um get into the detail of um
reporting back key performance
indicators value for money
as it stands at this point um it's it's
broad brush
because we have uh broad brush product
projects that we
we we've got on this on the long list
when we get into the detail about
actually agreeing what projects we're
going to support
that's the point at which we'll we'll
get into the detail uh and that will be
there will be clarity about that
um for for cabinets uh for overview and
scrutiny
uh so that uh uh the your committee can
hold the nhs to account for
the the value of the money that it's
spending on our behalf
uh in terms of the feedback loop i'll
i'll bring john back in on that one if i
if i may
thank you for clarification it's just to
ensure that there is efficiency
through the inputs yeah
sorry john sorry i
cut across you carry on thank you leader
um yes i was just going to say the um
we certainly notify um the
uh those who've bid whether they've been
successful or not
um i think we may have advised
um someone who asked um in the
in the last time why they weren't
successful certainly there's no
no reason why we can't but we do uh
certainly do engage with
the unsuccessful bidders uh so they
they're kept informed and they they do
know that uh whether they've been
successful or not
um a number of um projects on this
infrastructure list
uh were actually resubmitted from from
last time as well so
um hopefully we've we've got that
dialogue established
um in in some ways just perhaps um adds
to
council pemberton's um comments um
this is the new process for us we
haven't actually spent any
seal money as yet um inside
we're still trying to learn the process
about how we engage
and get the best submissions through so
in
the same way that although we've agreed
to spend some still money
we're still working through how we how
the detail that flows through
um it is a a bit of a learning curve for
us and
say as we as we go forward um we'll
we'll start to understand how best we
can do that
and get the the best outcomes certainly
um i think in the process of drawing up
some legal agreements
uh in respect of the money we are going
to spend
um and i think it's fairly uh standard
that the money
is um paid after completion
um or certainly a phased after phase
completion the reason
for that is that at the moment all the
all the bids are simply estimates
so they they may come in uh slightly
less and by which
instance we wouldn't want to um overpay
any money
so through our standard legal practices
we are looking to uh
contractually um ensure that we uh we
get
the money uh the value for money and the
projects delivered as expected
thank you thanks john
councillor kettle
you mute counselor kettle
you still can you hear me now yes yes
thank you mr chairman um yeah i'm just
trying to understand how
the money is set out in pages 19 to
about 30 something
actually flows through the accounts
because
reading the numerous tables there's an
awful lot of information in there
it's quite difficult to see the wood for
the trees
um and in simple terms we start off with
five million
as on table 1a 5.18 million
and we end up this is talking about
section 106 million
uh sorry when this is 106 payments and
we end up
on table 6a with 5.4 million
now if we look at what the money we've
had in
which is set out on
government lost it
if we if we look at um the money we've
received which is set out
on page 3a and we've received about 1.7
billion
but we've actually only spent in 5a
1.6 million if you add all that up
there's about 80 000 missing um
in the analysis uh so we start with 5.18
we spend one seven seven hours already
getting 1.77
we spend 1.6 and that all comes to about
five we should have about five
just over 5.3 million and according to
the statement
we've got just under 5.4 million i'm
just trying to
understand what that difference is john
thank you councillor um
the first point i'd i'd make is just to
to note that the tables i think is 1a1b
refer to the position as the 31st of
march
2019 um either the sort of starting
point
and then the subsequent tables are the
monies that
um come through in the financial year
that's that's being monitored
um i i don't want to uh
say something off the hoof um if i may
come back to you on that one
i'm satisfied the the numbers do add up
but uh perhaps we can uh discuss that
offline and just um
uh process you council just be satisfied
that the the monies are
are fully accounted for that's
acceptable leader thank you
i think that's probably the best way to
deal with it john
or we're probably in for a very long
session
no not i'm not suggesting that teddy i'm
very happy to take that forward
but i think depending on whatever john
and i come out with
um and and darren obviously as uh
portfolio holder
might be worth having a very quick
summary at the top saying this is where
we were this is what's come in
this is what's got out that's what we've
left with for the 106 monies
and the sale moneys and then all the
rest of tables below should fall
through or fall out of that first table
um and then it gives a true picture of
where is it coming and going
john yes thank you leader
i don't disagree with that point i
believe the structure of the ifs
is um to some extent a large extent set
by government
but that's not to say we can have
additional information explaining it a
bit better we are
i think it's a valid point and we look
into that offline thank you
thanks john uh councillor harvey
thank you mr chairman now i just want to
know i just want to
see if we can keep our feet on the floor
here um
it's one thing to welcome a spread of
uh potential projects from around
the district in total um it's quite
another to be able to finance them
the limited experience we've got so far
is that when we whittled
28 applications down to seven we still
couldn't manage to find
a way of spending the amount of money
that was available in chunks
worthwhile it seems to me that we are in
severe danger
of causing additional work which will
not lead to projects being financed
lots of disappointment all round and
unless we
put a cap on each application say 50k
or 100k as a maximum we're going to end
up with a lot of work
for very little return and very little
output we've got to be very careful
that our eyes aren't bigger than our
wallets
i see no other people wanting to make
points
so without further ado moving to the
recommendations to council on page nine
uh recommendations one two and three
uh can i have your agreement to it
please
uh cabinet and i would like to actually
at this point ask anne
to uh ensure that uh everybody
uh both everyone votes appropriately and
do you want to take over yes leader
and yeah just to note that we do for the
members of the public that might be
listening we did make sure that
everybody was in the meeting before the
meeting started
um so if i can start with yourself
counselor jefferson
uh agree councillor pendleton
agree councillor barker
agreed councillor cargill agreed
answer harvey agreed
councillor jennings agreed councillor
kettle
agreed councillor parry
agreed councillor schenten agree
unanimous thank you
thank you cabinets uh moving on uh we
now have
community portfolio public open space
options for management and maintenance
counselor cattle
uh thank you mr chairman yes
now this is an extremely welcome
development uh and relates to
the um history that we've seen
planning regulations have changed some
time ago whereby
on large developments public open space
was being made available for community
um and historically these have been
offered to parish council
uh to take on with a committed
commuted some from the developer for its
ongoing maintenance
for the use of um all residents the
village
members will will be aware that
um the amount of the commuted some has
reduced significantly as
offered by developers and rather than
parish councils taking on these sites
uh that they uh are retained by the
developer because the community some was
insufficient
uh for the parish council to be able to
maintain them
and then maintenance falls into the
management company
outside the control of residents and
there have been
a number of uh highly publicized stories
across the uk
um all those management charge
management companies
charging um residents
uh significantly significant sums and
significantly increasing sums
year on year um
as they have signed up on purchasing
their property
to having to pay these sums it is
effectively
uh a charge for which they cannot get
out and have
potentially have no control over
this proposal that we're putting forward
that in the event um public open spaces
are not taken up by parish councils
that by um default
paul back to the district council to
take on the public open space
and therefore remove the opportunity
for residents to be charged um
sums which may become excessive in the
future
but sums which they are having they are
forced to pay
for maintenance that public open space
so
it will be a huge improvement on
residents moving
acquiring sites in the future our
properties on these sites in the future
to know that maintenance on public open
space will either be
managed by the parish council or if that
does not happen it will be managed by
the district council for the benefit of
all
i recommend the proposal to my
colleagues
thank you i have councillor cargill and
then councillor junior wishing to speak
counselor cargill
thank you very much peter yes well as
you know i um i've been supporting this
for some time now
and it was one of our patches
the residents put it forward and we
decided to take this off
they called it police gates uh it was
all about
as council kettle said increasing
charges and no
no control over it and if you may
remember
um one of the residents spoke at full
council
so i'm delighted this has gone forward
uh not before time
uh and i'm just hoping now that we can
start to see some more consistency
and as your council kepler said not
increasing charges over which they have
no control
thank you very much indeed thank you
councillor cargill councillor junaid
this follows on from the question that i
asked uh on the 23rd of october 2019
at full council when i raised this
increasingly common practice
for developers requiring the um freehold
buyers of their properties to contribute
to the maintenance of communal green
spaces
uh through a leasehold arrangement at
that point
at the time i asked what arrangements
and what the council could do
um to uh to uh to
make sure that people were not caught in
these
uh what is called nationally please hold
arrangements
and um at the time i did say that
um i i wanted to make sure that people
for example
what it what actually happens is that
people on these estates
pay their normal council tax just like
everybody else does
the areas are public space that anybody
can walk on
and yet they also have to pay a
maintenance fee over and above their
council tax
now this is welcome i really do welcome
this this moving forward
but it does beg the question the areas
like the kineton
uh farm road estate just opposite me
already has these
arrangements in place they are not going
to have a
change in the arrangements by what you
are going to do this this will
move uh forward for new development
could you could you uh outline whether
there's anything that could be done for
those
developments that are already caught by
this very very unfair practice
thank you councillor junior councillor
parry
thank you leader i just wanted to add my
support to this report i know it's been
a topic
that um previous cabinets have been
working hard on to come to find a
solution and in fact it goes back um
quite a few years
um because i know it's been an issue in
a number of parishes so
um i'd just like to say you know it may
be long overdue but i know it's taken a
long time to sort of pull together
and really welcome it so um well done to
the officers
is what i'd like to say and thank you
chris thank you councillor parry
uh councillor kettle would you like to
respond
to the question councillor june had
raised
about the possibility of making any of
this retrospective
uh counselor junior thank you thank you
for that question and um i i
although as you clearly know i wasn't in
post at the time you asked that question
in fact um
i have only been in post for about two
weeks um
so um i can't i can't go back to that
time but
i have made inquiries already um
as to the opportunity for us to try and
relieve the
um the pressure on on the resident's
review
very adequately described
and clear that is not a planning matter
uh this is a planning act
this is a planning matter from the point
of now going forward
to try and ensure that this does not
happen in the future
looking back retrospect
then those who have acquired properties
on these estates
have actually comply have actually
signed up to leave
legal agreement between themselves and
uh
um i mean leaseholder freeholder is like
the wrong word it's it it's a sort of
strange legal position they're in um and
therefore there has to be some
uh at this stage there has to be some
legal
uh process which clearly is beyond the
re
my remit um of uh looking at the
planning policies
of the planning uh regulations
um it is i suspect something beyond the
reamers to this council
um at this stage maybe things will
change
uh but i have made an inquiry of our
legal team
i haven't had the response yet but i
have made that inquiry
not know you you were going to ask that
question council junior
uh to see if there is any legal
opportunity that we might have to
relieve those
residents on these type of dates and i
will pursue that and i will come back to
you um
possibly at the next cabinet meeting if
that's an appropriate time
thank you councilman councillor
pemberton and then councillor shenton
uh it's okay leader uh councillor kettle
has covered the point i was going to
come in on anyway
thank you councillor shenton yeah just
very quick comment on this thank you
chair
uh it's in my opinion this is a really
major step in eradicating this uh
sometimes the the these onerous levees
that
are colloquially known as fleece holes
and so i
definitely support this and the other
thing i wanted to point out is that
it's another example in here i was
working together with warwick district
council because we are using their
horticultural experience
to enable help us enable this proposal
so i definitely would support these
recommendations
fine thank you and without counselor
shenton i'll see no one else wishing to
speak
so uh the recommendations
are on page 63 there's a recommendation
subject to council adopting the
recommendation and then there's a
recommendation
to council so with that and can you do a
roll call of cabinet please
yes leader yourself for
councillor pemberton four
councillor barker four councillor
cargill
councillor harvey four
councillor jennings four
councillor
muted but i could see you mouthing for
councillor shenzhen four
do you none of us thank you um
so now we uh i think that's an excellent
piece of work and i think it's an
excellent solution
so uh very good news going forward i
think
so moving on the operations portfolio
councillor shenton uh waste and
recycling proposal
thank you chair the members have had i
had an opportunity to attend briefings
led by julie lewis or myself on what the
123 plus
eastern recycling proposal is all about
the presentations have been made to all
political parties with further
presentations at last week's
oversight and scrutiny committee meeting
uh which julie lewis led that
in addition i've had i have to say i've
had a very constructive meeting with the
leader of the lib dems councillor susan
junit
where we recognize the benefits of this
proposal
and i'm grateful for her time on this
i don't intend to go into great detail
on the proposal we'll gladly answer any
questions when i finish
my brief outline as the uh
combination of the papers on pages 67 to
76
plus the presentations that we've had
will hopefully be enough detail
for everyone however it's essential that
we consider both recommendations
as contained at the head of the proposal
on pages
on page 67 of your paper
the proposal seeks to create a joint
procurement and eventual contract
with warwick district council as a
partner
a sign again of our ever closer working
relationship which should benefit the
residents of both
districts the new contract if agreed
will commence in august 2022
some 21 months hence but it is essential
that we start the process
now it is a fact that our recycling rate
at around 60 percent and warwick
district councils
around 55 are well ahead of the
government's targets
of 50 for this year by moving to a one
two three plus approach with weekly food
waste collections
two weekly recyclable waste collections
and three weekly
residual waste collections we hope to
build on the great efforts
already made by our residents
we will help and encourage greater
recycling
through a media and messaging campaign
to make recycling easier
to understand and do the benefits are
increased recycling levels
reduced levels of waste go into
landfills separate food waste
collections
more fuel efficient fuel efficient
refuse vehicles and a reduction in
mileage
unraveled with smarter routing
especially on the borders between
warrick
and stratford districts as mentioned
just part of the proposal
includes introducing a weekly food waste
collection service
ahead of the government mandating this
which is
very probable will happen in the coming
years
the food waste will therefore not enter
the residual
or the green waste waste streams instead
it will
go to an anaerobic digester further
removing harmful greenhouse gasses from
landfill
food waste in particular releases
methane gas
which when the food waste decomposes is
up to 35 times
worse than co2 emissions for our climate
so this addresses and meets head-on at
climate
aspirations i hope and think that we all
acknowledge that this proposal is a big
step in reducing
harmful greenhouse gases from the waste
stream
and reducing knocks and co2 emissions
from our refused vehicles
through the procurement of even more
efficient vehicles
be they diesel electric or hydrogen
powered
this proposal is good for the
environment as well as mitigating the
inevitable
increase in gate fees and waste disposal
costs
when the current contract expires in
july 2022
and therefore ask that the
recommendations are
set out on page 67 of your papers
are accepted but i am happy to take
any questions prior to any vote
to the vote thank you councillor shenton
councillor junior do you have a question
yes um i've worked in the sex sector
in in the fourth in the past so uh i do
actually support the idea of joint
procurement
i think it's an excellent idea i also
support the idea of food waste being
collected
however one of the things that i'm very
keen on is that there should be
really good quality food waste
communication about where it's going to
what it will be used for as councillor
shenton said
uh being able to tell people that it's
being used for a green purpose like
um anaerobic digestion to produce a
biofuel
and then i think people will appreciate
that it is being used sensibly
resource efficiency has to be at the
heart of everything that we do
but can i i ask a couple of things
one is that it is essential that we have
uh benchmarking
and data collection as we go through
some of the questions some of the
examples that were put and named in the
report
i've checked on their data and their uh
benchmarking
they are not all terribly sound um
some of them are very good some of the
ones that are in the unomier report
and some of the ones mentioned by rap
some of the others are not
it is absolutely essential that
benchmarking is done
that data is collected and that uh
judgments are made um ongoing uh through
the process to in
in case anything um to make sure that
nothing is going awry so i'd like to ask
the question
will that be done and then the second
thing is could i
also ask um a question that was raised
at the
overview and scrutiny committee which
was uh looking
again i know the decision has been made
about a charge for green waste
but um we wanted to make sure that um
those people that are on less of an
income
it wasn't going to have a greater impact
on them despite the fact that they may
have had
larger gardens as a result of social
housing in the past
generally having larger gardens and and
the third thing is
um nappies um there is
we have to collect them at the moment
there is no other way of
dealing with them uh but i think there
needs to be
uh and it may be something that we need
to make um
a um a case for to to government to
find a way of dealing with nappies
because
it is a real big problem and finally
uh making sure that even though we've
got food waste collection
we do not want food waste to be ending
up in the residual waste because that
makes
um the the whole um the whole
cost of dealing with with this much much
more expensive as a result of
contamination how do we get that message
across
that we should not have food waste left
in the residual bins
thank you councillor junior um
interesting points i think when it comes
to
charging for green waste that decision
has already been
made uh so i see no further questions so
can we actually uh move to a vote on the
recommendations on page 67
to counselor during its other three
questions very briefly
okay so in terms of question one which
was about benchmarking
yes um as as many people will know
i i'm very hot on benchmarking and data
and data collection
yes is the answer we will be checking
all the way through
uh we need our leader has just covered
off
waste charges and i don't intend to go
down that route again
nappies that's that is a national
problem anyway
at the present they should be double
bagged they should be put in the
residual waste stream
that is the only way forward on those at
the moment and
for the uh food waste not been in a
residual waste
exactly right it shouldn't be in it
shouldn't be in
any waste street at the moment it should
be in the greenway stream
we don't want it in any other stream
because it is does contaminate
and that's why we want to bring bring in
a weekly food waste
collection service which will hopefully
take it out of all the streams and give
us a cleaner
product which is in more environmentally
friendly and a recyclable product that
is more sellable
going forward thank you leader thank you
thank you councillor kettle i see you've
got a very quick question
uh yes just confirmed the 240 liter
uh grey bins they will be retained until
they
tilt till they fall apart
yes yes indeed they the the in um
stratford we will only replace the 240
liter bin with a smaller bin
when as you say they fall apart or
for new developments and they will
automatically get
the smaller bin so it will be a phased
introduction
over a number of years these bins last
sometimes so
it's not going to be happening anytime
quickly so the impact
uh financially on stratford is
minimized
so and the logic about having a smaller
bill in the future
in the future is because there will be
less residual waste
uh from households as we've become more
efficient at recycling
indeed uh cancer kettle you you're
exactly right when we
look at what's in the residual bin now
and we we did this exercise last year
where we literally emptied the bins and
had them analyzed up to 30 percent of
what's
in the residual bin should actually be
in one of the other streams in any case
so if we take that out of the 240
bin that currently people have got that
would bring the the total amount that
should be in there on a two-week cycle
to 160 liters
which is therefore with increased
recycling
and better better use hopefully better
use
better packaging from manufacturers that
can be recycled
through our streams the moving to a
three weekly
waste collection will be achievable
there will be lots of communications
over the next 21 months about this about
how to recycle
right uh see counselor junior just
posted a question
on uh the chat but uh
i think you could deal with that offline
counselor shenton
so uh the recommendations on page 67
uh can you do a roll call of cabinet
please on
yes we'll start with yourself leader for
councillor pemberton paul
councillor barker four
councillor cargill
councillor harvey paul councillor
jennings
or councillor kettle
port councillor parry
and councillor shenton or unanimous
thank you anne thank you members of
cabinets so moving on
item seven uh leader
sorry um sorry leader i'm
i had wanted to make this point at the
beginning of the meeting but
there was no chat facility and my mute
button i'm afraid is
is playing up um
i've just wanted to raise my concern
about this next item because i only
received the papers
uh well they actually were i didn't get
the
the hard copy papers till thursday
evening and didn't get a chance to look
at the papers
properly until saturday the agenda's
over 200 pages plus
now this item is probably the most
important
and long-awaited document that we have
had
and i am really concerned that we've
we're literally
um trying to debate and and have a
conversation over it
and make some seriously important
decisions
when i don't believe that we've had
sufficient
time to look at it properly and you know
perhaps even question the officers
so mike thanks thanks councillor parry i
understand councillor pemberton
um thank you chair um uh i i
i hear what you say and and had and had
had it brought to my attention
uh that you and uh a number of other
members of cabinet had received papers
very late in the day
i'm able to help you out in any event
because some
fresh information has come to my
attention
around a particular site in the district
um that does bear some um
review as a potential expansion site
um this has only come this has only come
to my attention
um in the last couple of days and so
in conjunction with in discussion with
officers this morning
um i am going to request that we defer
this particular item
today to allow for officers
to take into account um
a site that um
has previously um
had uh permission for uh
gypsy and traveller pitches and may be
suitable
for inclusion as a site to go out to
consultation
i'm not willing to go into the details
of where that site is
because this has only just come into
into my
uh orbit and and uh there are some there
are some issues around planning and also
clearly uh you know the the site owner
needs to
to be contacted as in any event so uh
my my uh request with uh cabinets
forbearance
is that this matter be deferred until um
the next cabinet meeting in december to
allow for officers to
take a review of this additional
potential site which may factor into
our ability to meet our uh our
our um requirements for for for
additional bridges
but before i ask uh mr brookland has
indicated he wishes to speak but
do we need to put the deferment of this
to a formal vote
uh i suppose i'm asking uh mr buckland
that
hm now if you wish to defer the item you
certainly can
within your gift um i i i if i may just
respond to
the comments raised by councillor perry
a lot all items on camera are
extraordinarily important we
we accept that in relation to the papers
i can just be a survivor
i said earlier to camelot that all
papers were posted first class
from elizabeth house on friday evening
i'll take up with royal mail as to why
they won't receive with in some parts of
the district it's not a long way from
stratfor and i would have thought four
days it is more time than it should take
to
for deliveries
i think i would observe chief executive
that uh my own experience of war mail is
that uh i think since march it has uh
it isn't it has had challenges of its
own so i i think that uh
um yeah uh the uh it is
it isn't you know i think uh it is uh
yeah across the district people are
having struggles with that so
it's just what it is meanwhile thank you
councillor pemberton
so you wish this item to be deferred and
it will be brought back to the next
meeting of cabinet
correct i assume in that case i'm more
than happy to defer the item if it uh
results in a much improved paper
thank you thank you so moving on
uh revised council action plan
councillor cargill thank you very much
leader
i'm very pleased to bring this forward
it's been i think we can safely say
a traumatic year for us not just as a
council
as a country what i will say is that the
the council plan has changed and it will
change and i'm sure there'll be more
changes coming forward but what i would
like to say is that
i wish to commend the staff who worked
exceptionally hard
over this period um the
the working from home doing all those
sort of things getting the systems
working
and we have maintained the the running
of the council
and even achieved a number of the
actions
that we were we're looking to try and do
within the the previous plan
and if i refer to 1.5 uh
the protecting of staff councils
residents
maintain our business critical services
maintaining the decision-making
capability the council support
to businesses and support to the
vulnerable have all been carried out
and i think exemplary so um
it is a tricky one we're never going to
achieve all the the
the aims in the uh plan however
i do believe that we have done a
fantastic job and i commend it to
this cabinet i see nobody wishing to
raise any questions so the
recommendation is on page 111
uh so can i have your agreement to the
recommendation
on page 11 members of cabinet and do you
wish to take a roll call
yes leader yourself for
hansa pendleton for
councillor barker four
councillor cargill councillor harvey
four councillor jennings
or councillor kettle
[Music]
thank you on and thank you members of
cabinet so
moving on i terms item 9
proposed lisa 15 church street elizabeth
house
uh councillor harvey
thank you leader the purpose of this
non-controversial
paper is to ask the cabinet to give its
approval to the interim head of
resources and transformation
being authorized to agree the terms of
elise over offices
at 15 church street based on those set
out
on the blue piece of paper included with
the papers
the prospective tenant already occupies
adjacent
space in winton house the proposed rent
and service charge are those paid by the
previous tenant
those terms were set as the result of a
market exercise undertaken by
big woods in 2014 and they will be
uprated by increases in the rpi
in the intervening period i ask
therefore
that it be agreed that the cabinet gives
authority to the interim head of
resources and transformation
to enter into a lease on this suite of
officers at 15 church street
as detailed in the paper thank you
leader
thank you uh councillor harvey and it
looks as though you're absolutely
correct there are no
questions arising so it definitely was
non-controversial
and do you wish to do a roll call please
yes leader yourself uh four
councillor pendleton four
councillor barker poor councillor
cargill
or chancellor harvey
for councillor jennings for
chancellor kettle for councillor parry
for councillor shenton
or unanimous leader
thank you anne thank you members of
cabinet so
moving on it's councillor harvey again
revenue budget monitoring
counselor harvey did you want me to deal
with capital budget monitoring oh
sorry yes you're absolutely right i've
skipped the paper
uh capital budget monitoring councillor
harvey that was a very nice try for
which i'm almost appreciative chairman
the purpose of this paper is to keep
members informed
of the progress made over the first six
months of the year
in undertaking the council's intended
level of capital expenditure this year
the position in relation to the capital
budget for the year has remained
unchanged since the cabinet last met
table 1 on page 131
demonstrates the intention to undertake
expenditure of 10.7 million pounds this
year
including section 106 projects
taking into account additional funds of
2.9 million pounds budgeted for this
year
this will result in the balance of the
council's accumulated capital receipts
and grants
being reduced over the year assuming all
capital projects budgeted are to be
delivered
from 6.4 million pounds to an overspend
of 1.4 million pounds
paragraph 1.5 indicates that capital
expenditure
of 1.1 million pounds has either already
been undertaken
or had been committed by the end of
september
in the first six months of the year
therefore the sums
either spent or committed amount to
10 of this year's available budget of
10.7 billion pounds
appendix 2 on pages 141
to 144 provides summary information
concerning the various projects
yet to be funded through section 106
agreements
i'd like again to draw attention to the
amount of funds
allocated under section 106 agreements
that relates to
affordable housing at the end of
september this amounted to
3.5 million pounds i'm pleased to note
that the housing investment panel agreed
at its most recent meeting on the 21st
of october
to review these financial contributions
at least twice per year
last financial year saw the number of
affordable homes
provided in the district rise to 491
a record number for the district and
more than the number provided by
any other council in warwickshire in the
same period
against this background the panel will
continue to assess
requests received and to commit
available financial contributions on a
case-by-case basis
where they meet the council's strategic
priorities
where they provide additional houses and
where they offer
value for money i ask leader therefore
that the current position on capital
expenditure and income for the period to
the end of september
2020 be noted
uh thank you councillor harvey and
very good news there on uh affordable
houses
so we need to receive this do we need to
take a vote on this
on in that case uh we note the
recommendation on page 131
uh moving on uh this time i've got it
right
revenue budget monitoring once again
councillor harvey
thank you chairman before i start my
narrative
can admonish
counselor kettle for not having spotted
the deliberate error
in the paper can i draw your attention
to
the conclusion and the an ultimate
figure uh estimated balance of
three four four three eight one seven
uh that i'm afraid is an incorrect
figure for which i apologize
the correct figure is set out in the
page opposite page one four
eight and it's actually three nine
five three eight one seven as shown in
the table
in paragraph seven uh with that
uh apology and proviso i would like to
carry on
uh the purpose of this report is to
inform the cabinet of the revenue
picture
of the council's finances to the end of
september
2020. i'd like to begin by asking
members to turn to
appendix three on page
one five five
this shows that the net budget to be
financed by the council this year
is now 20.8 million pounds
if we now turn to appendix 2
on page 153 we can see that the budget
for the whole year
is for total expenditure of 28.2 million
pounds and total income from various
sources
of 11.5 million pounds the difference
between these two numbers
28.2 minus 11.5
is 16.7 in rounded numbers
together with the net cost of the total
the cost of
benefits of 186 000 pounds this
represents the total amount to be funded
from various sources i.e
16.9 million pounds as set out in
appendix 2.
in addition appendix 2 also sets out
that as a result of the covid 19
pandemic the council has received civil
contingencies funding
from the government of 37 million pounds
of which 34.8 million pounds has been
distributed
in ways consistent with the government's
intentions
leaving a balance of 2.2 million pounds
at the end of september
turning to the position at the end of
period six
we can see that in round terms the
council's expenditure
of 15.7 million pounds was
735 000 pounds more than budgeted
this reflects a variety of decisions
across the council's activities
in light of current very changed
circumstances
the impact of the covid19 pandemic
is similarly illustrated in the
shortfall against
budgeted income to the end of september
of 5 million pounds
principally due to shortfalls in revenue
of 1.8 million pounds
generated from fees and charges
principally 956 000 pounds of revenue
lost from the district's car parks alone
the combination of these results
means that the net cost of all services
provided in the first six months of the
year
was two and a half million pounds
greater
than had been budgeted section three of
the paper
identifies the principal items of
variance from their budgeted figures
during the period from april to
september
while section 4 provides estimates for
the out turn
for the year in full managers and heads
of service
are again to be commended for providing
these estimates
in the face of such continuing
uncertainty
section six of the paper demonstrates
the severe strain
that the pandemic is having on the
council's reserve position which at this
stage is estimated will be reduced
from 8.9 million pounds
to 4 million pounds by the end of the
financial year
this estimate takes no account of the
impact
of the lockdown undertaken during
november
which could see the council's finances
impacted by a figure
of the order of a further 750
thousand pounds importantly
appendix four identifies the council's
current earmarked reserves
which will come under close scrutiny
in the coming weeks and months as part
of the budget preparation process
for 2021-22
subject to any further information that
mr hill
might be in a position to provide about
the prospects
for this year's spending review and
to any questions members may have i
ask that the report is received
thank you councillor harvey and
councillor junaid has a question
councillor junaid yes it's just a query
uh i had understood uh the government
was to
uh refund some of the costs uh of
uh responding to covert 19 uh by
councils
and that for example they were to get
some money back for
um loss of income for for example for
for car parking etc how much
have we actually had to to uh you know
cover the cost and particularly what
kind of some did we get
to to um off put the loss of charge for
car bargaining uh that's a detailed
question
do you mind if i ask um mr hill to
respond to that with the accurate
numbers
um yeah thank you um the uh
fees and charges figure that we have
calculated
and submitted to government is just over
six hundred thousand
we haven't received any of that yet um i
had an email today to
suggest that we may receive that money
sometime later november the 27th
of november in fact is the deadline for
the government paying that amount
so we should receive that then we're
expecting to receive a similar amount
for the rest of the year
but we'll have to revise that obviously
in the light of the
of lockdown 2 and the implications for
that
thank you mr hill uh thank you also
councillor harvey i think the report
well demonstrates the uh
uh significant impact kerby 19 and the
loss of revenue
has had on our finances and obviously
um it will be interesting to see what
the government
actually allows us to do in terms of
council tax
and it will be even more interesting to
see what funding the government provides
for the year 21 22.
so with that members of cabinet can i
ask you to accept
the proposals on page 145.
uh we don't need to take a vote on this
dewey on
in that case uh the proposals are
accepted
so moving on response to the osc
recommendations from the policies and
practice task and finish group
uh this is paper starting on page 159
there were seven recommendations
going through it uh just to say that
some of the recommendations uh
if we were to implement them would
prevent
provide some real resource challenges to
the council
i think it's pretty well known that kobe
does have a significant impact
on the workload it's put an awful lot
more pressure
on an awful lot of people and frankly in
a lot of cases we just don't have the
resource
to implement some of these
recommendations
uh turning to some of the specifics
recommendation
to parity of esteem uh that's pretty
much
set out in 161
to 163 the key decisions
uh one seven uh
what we would like to do is maintain the
statutory 28-day
forward plan supplement this with an
indicative cabinet program
we can't easily commit to a forward plan
of six months
given the sheer level of uncertainty
around
and the reality is that things change
extremely rapidly and that is coupled
with the
issue in terms of resourcing in terms of
standing panels uh
reality actually is osc can establish
task and finish groups to look at
specific issues
and we think that ought to continue
also need to point out that as we get
more involved in working with water
district council
we will need to create some kind of
joint scrutiny
function or operation and that also
will take up resources so
we carry on with the existing
arrangements
and it's up to will i see if they want
to
to establish task and finish groups
item one nine cabinet scrutiny protocol
uh myself and the chair of osc
uh have agreed to meet regularly
and i must admit i apologize for the
fact that i haven't met
before the last meeting they've always
seen but that was partially because
i made the mistake of taking a week's
holiday
so are there any questions or comments
on the paper please
joe barker you have a uh question
yeah um i i'm
concerned about um recommendation two
um recommendation one six
and seven and potentially as amended
happy with
um but it's but it's uh number two
that i am concerned about which is
parity for steam
um having chaired um the
ovian scrutiny committee myself i'm
conscious that
one could always push it further and
further and further and ask for more
and more work and more and more reports
and whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing is irrelevant at the moment
because none of us have got the
bandwidth for it
but in any event i would never have
considered that the overview and
scrutiny committee ought to have parity
of esteem
parity of respect yes but
not parity for steam because that just
to me
puts osc on exactly the same footing as
cabinet and i just
that that just doesn't work for me um so
i would like to amend that very very
small way from esteem to respect
are you making that a formal proposal i
am making that a formal proposal
do i have this our councillor schenten
the second did that
uh meanwhile council o'donnell you have
a comment and counselor junior do you
wish to respond
counsel o'donnell thank you leader um
first of all i'm just going to put on
record i'm very disappointed
in councillor barca's recommendation
especially leader when both yourself
and mr buckland and i had a meeting and
went through this and we know that
nationally
opium scrutiny does have parity of
esteem at a number of other councils so
i'm
puzzled as to the motivation behind
asking for that
what is classed by council bach was a
tiny amendment
i would argue it is not i'd ask to look
at other models
elsewhere i would also ask for further
clarification around the costing of the
resources
that has meant that the recommendations
we had performed as a committee
were not deemed to be possible so just
like a little bit more information about
the resources that
we simply can't fund at the moment and
i'd also draw attention
the cabinet's attention to the fact that
our neighbors at warwick have a
much longer work program than the 28
days
if we're drawing parallels with them it
seems to be a little bit of a mix about
which parallels we'll be drawing
so i do want to note that i am
disappointed that councillor barclays
felt it necessary
to note it as parity of respect rather
than parity of esteem as we had already
discussed that
thank you thank you uh
councillor junard yes
uh indeed the the um the term parity of
esteem was modeled
on the uh practice common practice and
common um
wording used by many other councils
and it means that the it is recognized
that the ability to scrutinize and hold
to account
is a very valued function of
of a council as are the select
committees for example in the house of
commons
which have parity of esteem so it is a
fairly common
uh wording that is used and a common
process
and i also understand that
and agree concur with um councillor
o'donnell
that uh the practice of uh longer
feed-in times uh
and are common also particularly warwick
district and i believe that they also
take the
they also take the uh the role of parity
of esteem uh forward as well
thank you councillor junior
mr buckland do you want to respond on
the resources issue
thank you chairman and yeah we've
obviously had the conversation and
welcome the conversation with the share
of your overview and stupid committee on
the recommendations
quite quite simply at the time but we've
just come up a a revenue budget
monitoring report that shows that we're
4.1 million pounds in deficit this
particular year
and looking forward we already know that
we are going to have to take some
significant sums out of the medium-term
financial plan
in order for the cows to be viable in
relation to the three proposals for
policy performance and budget
panels we already have
in place a standing budget panel so the
budget is reviewed by the opium
committee in the period from january
february every year in any case
in relation to performance reports are
already taken through
to the osc specifically in relation to
foreign monitoring
and that's taken through twice a year
through through the overview and group
committee
and also members of the cavalier called
to the agreements grouping committee
on a rotating basis for questions in
relation to their particular function
and finally in relation to policy
the the the normal approach within
stratfor that when
a policy issue has come forward then the
separate rsc task group will be
established
for that particular purpose now your
committee team
are particularly stretched at the moment
particularly stretching in managing
meetings by our teams
and and at least for the foreseeable
future we can just see no way that we
can resource this along with all the
other challenges that we have at the
moment
thank you mr buckland uh councillor
barker
you've got your handle by council of
pemberton
sorry um i just wanted to come back on
the fact that
you know i i can't remember how long i
chaired the osc for but
i would i don't regard respect as
anything other than just a change of
word i know
what that you would that people seem to
use the word esteem
but the problem i have with it is that
it seems to think that you're putting
osc in cabinet
um in terms of resourcing on a level
playing field
which i just don't think is possible
and i'm grateful to mr buckland for
pointing out exactly
how in the whole we are um lots and lots
of things
we we just we genuinely cannot afford to
do them it's going to be a toss-up
between
what we can do for our residents and
what we can talk about and i know what i
would rather do
so i'm sticking with i'm afraid i want
it changed to
parity of respect not esteem uh i've now
got
councillor cargill councillor pemberton
and then
uh councillor donald and councillor
junard
so councillor cargill thank you chair
um yeah i must admit i thought it was
a parody of respect uh and that's what i
was
expecting to see and then obviously it
came in later on
and of course 1.163 said there must be
respect for the function of oc of course
there must
um i've supported it the oc function
since it was uh
well i'll use the word reintroduced um
beefed up shall we say
uh and i fully support the that function
but i go with
council barca on this one i think that
at the end of the day uh there has to be
a difference
at the end of it the offer the the chair
of osc
has the same um conduits into
the offices and they will give them the
same have the same
um responses and such like so i don't
see an issue there and i'm quite happy
to second
um this change which i think is minor
too
councillor pemberton on the forward work
program
mute counselor pemberton
i fall in for the mute thing i do
apologize
um i was just going to pick up um and i
i hear what uh is said around
um the work that you know looking
forward and also looking forward at the
program
you know that warwick have got but i
think the comment i would make there is
that
both us and warwick are going to have
some
very tough decisions to make about our
ability
to service all of the things that we
want to do and i think that
the the pushback is one with a heavy
heart to be perfectly honest that
we've got so many things on the go
and i'll i'll just i'll just throw this
out open to you
and and please don't take this other
than as a for example
you know we have a certain amount of
bandwidth how much time are we going to
invest
in you know committee a versus panel b
for example because the officers can
only support
so much we can only support um
so much in terms of forward planning in
an environment
where it's really uncomfortable for all
of us i thrive on chaos but
the rest of you are all very sensible
need to have plans ahead
and we are living in a chaotic world and
so things are moving so quickly and
i think the you know it is just a
reflection of the reality
that can we continue to do
the things that we've done in the way
that we've done them in the past
in the foreseeable you know the i was on
you know i spoke to somebody yes
earlier this morning i just don't get
the time to to do the work between
the meetings that i'm in back to back
whereas before when we had a
a black and white world when we were all
meeting each other and
driving a couple of hours to meetings we
had that down time and
all that prep time now we're just going
from thing to thing to thing and that's
for our offices as much as for members
of the
of the council so i think we have got to
really challenge ourselves about what we
can do
i think as far as the the the parity is
concerned i think the the question is
about
the practicalities can the overview and
scrutiny function
operate in a way that is
is uh delivers what it's supposed to do
on the tin which is to
overview and scrutinize and to challenge
and i don't think
there's anything in any anything that
anybody has said
that has any desire to push back on that
or to minimize it in fact
you know we all welcome scrutiny it
makes us make better decisions
so i think if i if there's any feeling
that it said
uh there's to you know looking to
downgrade
the importance of osc i think it's not i
think it's just trying to
work through a set of new realities
okay council o'donnell and councillor
junaid
thank you leaders so actually councillor
and you've just summed up
by complete confusion with councillors
balkan councillor
need to change one word we're not
changing what overview and scrutiny does
i appreciate mr buckland outlining the
resourcing issues we accept that
but can you therefore explain to me when
you are giving us such large agendas to
work through
scrutinize such important key elements
of our vision for stratford
why you cannot as is nationally
practiced
within local government keep the words
parity of esteem why is that so
offensive to councillor barker
and to other members of cabinet who've
seconded that amendment
what is the difference between keeping
esteem and respect and we are carrying
out the work
listed there we've accepted that we will
not have the standalone
um groups that we'd asked for we've
accepted that we're having a shorter
working plan we accepted down to mr
buckland's resourcing arguments we
accept that but why therefore
when you're asking us to carry out that
level of work is it so offensive to you
that we have parity of esteem it is not
like any other committee they're big
decisions that we're scrutinizing with
you
we give you a good level of scrutiny and
i do not understand
why that has caused such offense it's
been deemed necessary to change the
terminology of it
and i'm speaking on behalf of my
committee saying this
council that certainly put the cast
among the pigeons hasn't it
i i would like to i would like it
i i have proposed the change because
having done the job myself i don't
believe that parity of esteem
is appropriate and like i just did
and it was it's a discussion that we we
have had
um i was as surprised uh as mark was
to see parity of esteem in here not
parity of respect
because we've already discussed it
and they come in that parity of esteem
actually has a legal definition
in in a way that uh parity of respect
does not
parity of esteem has has is used
commonly
in the legal profession uh for example
in in the term mental health provision
versus uh other health provision
priority of esteem is used as part of
that
legislation that could make sure that
the one is seen
as um as not just equally
deserving of respect but is on an equal
has an equal
legal backing uh background to it it is
a legal term
that is used in a way that parity bit
respect does not have that legal
definition
okay right uh
in that case i've had uh
councillor barker proposing a change on
recommendation too
from parity of esteem to parity of
respect
that has been seconded by uh
councillor cargill amongst others so
now i assume uh and we put this to a
vote
yeah yes
fine okay so just to clarify
uh lady you want to vote on this
amendment first
and then you want to follow that up with
a vote on the actual
list of the recommendations in the
report is that the right way around to
do it and
you need what you need to clarify
exactly what everybody's voting on
in that case the first vote is on the
amendment proposed by councillor barker
to change parity of esteem to parity of
respect
and then we will vote on the
recommendation uh on
page 159
okay would you start with yourself
leader four
answer pendleton councillor barker
or councillor cargill or
councillor harvey full
councillor jennings or
councillor kettle
hi councillor kettle
okay welcome back councillor parry
welcome kevin paul
thank you thank you councillor shenton
oh okay so that's unanimous leader
thank you now turning to uh the
recommendation
on page 159 and that recommendation
will be subject to the revision uh just
accepted right
yes so yeah we'll start with you
go around yep
for council pemberton
jennings
okay we'll come back answer parry
for councillor shenton
paul was that you counselor kettle
okay we can take the vote as carries
thank you so moving on then to
on block items uh these
are for noting and there's been no
requests made
to actually discuss any of the items
so they strap it up on even markets
forums
165 to 170 for noting
so i assume that's noted uh no urgent
business
uh we don't need exclude the public
because we've already dealt with uh the
proposed lease of 15
church street i am correcting saying
that am i not
yes you're correct we didn't need to do
that fine
in that case at five o'clock meeting
closed
thank you everyone bye